can the iphone 13 pro max dethrone the
s21 ultra as the best flagship
smartphone well today we will find out
in this ultimate comparison we're going
to test everything from the designs
displays performance for the processor
and the graphics speaker comparison
cameras and much more let's start out by
comparing the exteriors and we have a
ton of differences the samsung has these
curved glass corners it's really smooth
whereas the iphone since the 12s we have
the boxy design of course the camera
bumps look much different as well apple
is embracing their camera bumps it's
much bigger this year and the samsung
it's almost like they tried to blend it
in other than just how deep that camera
bump is the s21 ultra definitely looks
larger and as you can tell it is taller
although with that is slightly narrower
as well it has a taller display and even
though it does look bigger it is
actually lighter than the iphone 13 pro
max this thing is definitely bulky we
have the bigger cameras this year of
course it's using stainless steel for
the frame instead of aluminum and that
makes it heavier the samsung has all of
the buttons on its right hand side so
the left side is completely free whereas
the iphone it sticks with its old
traditional method and also has this
large 5g antenna for a millimeter wave
and then on the bottom of course we have
usb type-c compared to lightning and the
samsung has a sim card slot there which
also supports a micro sd card which is
great to be able to expand your memory
and save some money whereas the iphone
you're just stuck with whatever you buy
flipping to the front of the phones we
have a ton of differences the first
being that the s21 ultra has a curved
glass edge display compared to the
iphone which is completely flat right up
until the edge of the frame and because
of that we have this bezel that goes all
around it is even but you definitely
notice it compared to the samsung which
has these super slim side bezels because
of that curved display next we have that
notch on the iphone it did get smaller
this year about 20 smaller but it's
still noticeable compared to samsung's
hole punch which is much more minimal
now with that apple moved the earpiece
speaker right up there close to the
frame which is the same thing that
samsung has but theirs is hidden you
basically don't even notice it we're
going to put these displays head to head
in contrast hdr brightness all of that
but first i want to go ahead and test
out the speakers because the s21 ultra
has amazing speakers and apple has
improved them so let's go ahead and see
which ones sound better and which ones
are louder
[Music]
all right guys wow that was close let me
know your thoughts down in the comments
section below loudness was identical i
even used my apple watch and both of
them hit 78 decibels so the iphone got
way louder than last year because back
then it was smoked and with us for a
sound quality it actually beats out the
samsung so it was able to maintain more
bass and the highs are actually a little
bit sharper as well so even though it
got louder they kept the better sound
quality from before either way you're
not going to complain with either of
these but the iphone does take the win
and now let's compare the displays where
the specs seem fairly close we have up
to 1200 nits on the iphone and 1300 for
the s21 ultra both are 120 hertz but
there are some differences let's start
out with that brightness i'm gonna go
ahead and max out both of these in
manual brightness mode vadim adjusted
his camera so these aren't blown out and
as you can see the iphone gets much
brighter when you're controlling it
yourself and asking it to be brighter
for certain situations it goes up to a
thousand nits whereas the s21 ultra goes
up to about 500 or so if you're
controlling it yourself of course if you
go outside and if you're using auto
brightness mode then they are very
similar both of them will adjust their
white balance to match your environment
but the iphone does prefer a warmer
color and the other difference i see is
color and
brightness shift the samsung when you're
viewing it from an angle it gets much
dimmer and it gets a lot more blue than
the panel that's in the iphone now both
of these are 120 hertz panels meaning it
is super smooth when you're using them
and they both go down all the way to 10
hertz saving you battery life now there
have been some people that are
complaining online saying that the
promotion tech with the iphone it's not
really 120 hertz and that's because with
the iphone when you're scrolling it will
only give you the amount of refresh rate
that you need so if you're scrolling
slowly like this you will only get say
maybe 60 90 100. basically it just
matches how fast you're scrolling
whereas the samsung whenever you scroll
it's at 120 hertz or if you're flipping
through apps or anything else but you be
the judge for yourself with our slow
motion footage can you tell the
difference in smoothness to me
personally i can't tell both are ultra
smooth and of course running at the low
refresh rate when you're scrolling
slowly does save you battery life and
now let's push these screens to the
extreme with hdr video i had to turn
that top camera's exposure down all the
way because of how bright this iphone is
both are playing hdr both are maxed out
in brightness look how much brighter the
iphone is the crazy thing is last year
the samsung beat out the iphone and now
apple is back with the vengeance it's
not that the samsung is a really dim
phone or anything like that the iphone
has just gotten much brighter this year
now of course if we zoom in here we do
notice that notch cutting into our image
or our video much more so than that
little camera cutout both screens have
nice contrast nice detail this is 4k
video being played back here but if you
want the best hdr it is now iphone the
13 pro max that takes the win and now
let's get to performance we're gonna see
the cpu performance graphics performance
we're gonna see 5g speeds but we're
going to start out with geekbench 5. of
course the new iphone 13s they have the
a15 bionic processor with the five
graphics cores with the s21 ultra we
have the version with the snapdragon 888
this thing has 12 gigs of ram compared
to six gigs we have eight cores compared
to six cores but that doesn't tell the
whole story the iphone goes up to 3.23
gigahertz that's crazy high compared to
one core being able to hit 2.84 over
here with a snapdragon but let's go
ahead and run the cpu benchmark all
right we have a result and man
this is a big difference of course even
last year's a14 beat out the s21 ultra
but here we are seeing a difference in
60 of 64
in single core score and over 40
in multi-core score the iphone 13 per
max is way more powerful and but of
course in day-to-day use with most apps
the s21 ultra is more than fast enough
the difference really comes in when
you've used this phone for two years
three years four years it will still be
fast and it'll still run all the brand
new apps that is cpu let's go ahead and
go back and we are gonna do the graphics
test and bam we have our results
geez that is not looking good the 13 pro
max's score is more than three times
higher
326 percent faster that is incredible of
course we had a good difference
beforehand now this new one is a huge
jump especially with the pro model as
the five core graphics and in this test
of course we're using vulcan and it
tests a lot of different things we have
face detection depth of field gaussian
blur particle physics it's not like a
gaming test but this is just the raw
performance for those kind of tasks so
you're doing photo editing video editing
stuff like that but what happens if we
take a look at actual gaming performance
i have 3d marks wildlife right now we're
going to run the regular mode that way
we can actually see something happen and
we're not just going to get like five
frames per second in 4k mode so let's go
ahead and get started even visually we
can see a difference in smoothness right
now we're running at uh 27 26 frames per
second compared to
60 ish right there we have 59 we're
actually hitting the hard cap of this
test that is very weird compared to 33
here we have 55 33 wow so we have a big
difference in performance let's see how
this changes as the phones heat up here
that ended faster than i was expecting
but we have our results here and yeah
this is still a big difference we have
about 70 or 72 percent higher score for
the iphone so it's no longer 326 percent
in gaming it's not that big of a
difference but we still have 32 frames
per second average for the samsung and
basically 54.9 or 55 average for the
iphone now what i'm curious about is are
we really limited by that cap if we look
right over here
a lot of times more than half the time i
was hitting that 60 fps so does that
affect that overall average frame rate
so i'm going to go ahead and run
wildlife extreme
this is going to be the 4k one where
we're definitely not going to hit that
60 fps limit and let's see if we keep
the same difference or if it's going to
be even bigger okay all right well i'm
glad that i ran that test because as you
guys can see we have 17.1 here which is
low this is a 4k test compared to 8.5
frames per second so now the score is
actually a little bit more than double
instead of 70 percent now it's more than
double so it's what i don't know 200 or
so a little over that so yes that was
actually limiting the iphone hitting
that 60 frames per second cap so overall
for gaming it looks like the iphone 13
pro max has a little bit more than
double the graphics performance than the
s21 ultra if you guys want to see a
gaming test head to head maybe even with
one 20 hertz games who knows you guys
let us know comment down below and now
let's test something that very few
channels do the speed at which your
phone can actually connect when you
spend this much money you want it to be
fast so we have speed tests open here on
both both connected same server we're
gonna run one at a time to make sure
there's no bottlenecks and what's
interesting is that the s21 ultra it
shows four out of five bars where iphone
only shows two out of four but let's see
if that matters we're gonna start out
with the iphone bam we are at 80 84 85
right there keep in mind we're actually
inside of a concrete office building
right now it stopped at 87 so that's
pretty good and as far as the upload
just a bit above 20. and now for the s21
ultra bam look at that
90 93 95 slightly high oh no it's
slowing down i shouldn't have said that
look at that we got 98 there right at
the end it kicked up a little bit and
for upload
also a little bit faster looking at 32
31 but it doesn't have that side antenna
for 5g but we are not using millimeter
wave here uh this is low band so it
looks like the samsung does take the win
by just a bit with both the upload and
the download i remember we got like 15
here it sucked now these speeds are much
better stepping outside on their roof we
first tested the samsung and it got a
much faster 256 download and 52 for the
upload and then we pulled out the iphone
and it got
365 megabit per second download and a
higher 63 for the upload so these are
fantastic results much faster than
indoors literally just stepped out of
the concrete here but what's interesting
is that the samsung outside showed five
out of five bars the iphone started two
out of four then it jumped up to three
so that just proves that the bars really
don't matter and there was a tear down
that actually revealed that the 13 pro
max has the same snapdragon x60 modem as
the s21 ultra so the main modem is the
same the difference are the antennas and
the iphone is better at least outdoors
and now let's talk about the cameras of
course if you're spending this much
money you want great cameras and the
cool thing is we just did an unbiased
camera comparison against both of these
where you can actually watch choose your
favorite photos and then find out which
phone you prefer both these are
powerhouses we have crazy lenses but the
samsung has a high resolution main
camera 108 mega pixel compared to 12 the
front facing camera is 40 megapixel
compared to 12 it also has the same
three times zoom and then it has a 10x
telescopic lens so hardware wise this
one definitely takes the win but what
happens when you add in the software
element so make sure you guys go out and
check that video after this one is a
whole lot of fun and shows off some
massive differences i don't know if i
should give him a hint video what do you
think
now we won't give you guys a hand just
go ahead and watch that video to see
which one has the better cameras and now
let's talk about battery life the s21
ultra has a massive 5 000 milliamp hour
battery whereas the 13 pro max it went
from under 4 000 now to a 43 50 milliamp
hour battery so definitely smaller but
with that the battery life is actually
much better on the iphone
in test online we're seeing about an
hour and a half more screen on time
which is huge the s21 ultra used to be
the king there but now the iphone is
almost 10 hours of screen on time and
that is thanks to the a15 bionics super
power efficient cores and along with
that the 120 hertz screen will adapt
when you're swiping and using it instead
of being locked at 120 hertz and that
also saves power so the iphone is
definitely the winner by the way neither
of these come with chargers if you guys
want one you guys can pick up one of
these anchors that is only 11 or 12
bucks with folding prongs 20 water this
thing does a great job as far as prices
the iphone comes in at eleven hundred
dollars just like it did before compared
to twelve hundred dollars for the s21
ultra both with 128 gigabytes of storage
the iphone surprisingly is cheaper and
now for the final verdict did the iphone
13 pro max dethrone the s21 ultra as the
best smartphone in the world the true
flagship king and i would have to say
yes last year the samsung was much
better or i guess it was this year when
it came out had better hardware all
around us no doubt better battery life
to screen but now the screen in the
iphone is also 120 hertz but more energy
efficient it has better battery life has
faster 5g speeds much better cpu
performance and much much better
graphics performance and design looks
great and also in the camera division it
wins a lot it is way way better you guys
have to see that video overall i would
have to give the win now to the iphone
13 pro max as the flagship king but you
guys let us know your thoughts down in
the comment section below go ahead and
click that subscribe button above if you
guys want to subscribe and help us reach
1 million subscribers we would
definitely appreciate it check out one
of those great videos right over there
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]